Apple's new iPad pro goes on sale today
it's a big tablet made to do lots of
things but one of the things Apple talks
a lot about is how it could be useful
for creative professionals I am NOT one
of those but we have lots of them here
at wire so we gave the new iPad pro to a
bunch of different people and then we
ask them what they think it's extremely
responsive it really feels like I'm
drawing with a pencil in the way it
shades and the way I can adjust the
tools it's the best digital version of a
pencil I've used I wouldn't necessarily
say that I would take it to the
professional level as an artist because
that's really a tactile thing I need a
pad pen paper canvas paint spray paint
walls whatever it is I use to create my
art work to create foundational drawings
and things of that nature I would
definitely get rid of these because I
can draw anywhere anytime I don't have
to worry about crinkled paper carrying a
plethora of pencils and pens and ink I
can sit on the airplane and draw a bunch
of sketches and know that when I land I
have a library of things that I can use
for reference the pen was super easy to
use and works really well there is a
lack of control because when you're
working on a per file professionally you
need to be able to manipulate it in a
lot of different ways personally I would
probably use Photoshop fix for pictures
I take day-to-day of my family pictures
I take for myself that I don't intend to
use professionally not being able to see
the adjustments that I'm doing and not
be able to delete them as I want to
makes it a little bit problematic iMovie
inside of the iPad pro has all of the
basic tools you need for making a video
you can import your Clips you can line
them up on a timeline and you can put in
music tracks or other audio tracks it's
pretty obvious what all the tools are
based on icons it's really simple to use
very user-friendly what I like about the
iPad pro is that you're able to touch
things I really like having de facto
sense and being able to move my clips
around physically as a filmmaker and
someone who's worked in celluloid I
really like the the physical work of
putting a film together and this kind of
takes me back to that
I wouldn't use iPad Pro professionally
as it is now just because it doesn't
have a lot of the tools that I use on a
day-to-day basis such as color editing
audio editing layering of tracks things
like that but that said it's a lot of
fun to play with for any filmmaker I
think and you can do really simple
things and still make a beautiful video